[Musique]
l'argent va permettre de financer les
opérations c'est les opérations à cœur
ouvert donc on va faire venir les
enfants ils vont attaquer dans des
familles d'accueil on a besoin on aura
besoin de famille d'accueil pour ses
enfants et on va financer les hôpitaux
et on a un forfait de 12000 euros pour
repérer ses enfants ils vont avoir une
petite convalescence dans la famille
d'accueil d'un mois et demi et après ils
vont rentrer chez eux ils vont galoper
jouer au foot à la marelle je sais bon
une vie d'enfant quoi c'est fantastique
[Musique]
on opère 300 enfants par an la liste
d'attente elle est pléthory comme vous
l'imaginez bon mais 300 est-ce que c'est
bien le 301e il aimerait bien qu'on en
fasse un peu plus mais les 300 premiers
sont déjà contents donc voilà c'est déjà
quand même des gros volumes c'est
beaucoup d'enfants faut des familles
d'accueil il faut des places
hospitalières il faut amener ses enfants
et surtout les suivre après dans la vie
voilà cette année on fête le 4 millièmes
enfants et on est content qu'on va faire
4000 et deux enfants grâce à cette
soirée
[Musique]
on cherche des amis d'accueil je voulais
dire on a de plus en plus d'enfants qui
arrivent avec tout ce qui s'est passé on
va avoir des sous on va trouver les sous
mais il nous faut aussi surtout des
familles d'accueil ces deux mois de
votre temps les enfants ils sont opérés
au Plessis-Robinson donc à côté de Paris
c'est deux mois de votre vie c'est vrai
que c'est un gros investissement de
temps parce qu'il faut être disponible
tout le temps mais c'est tellement
fantastique que ça vaut vraiment le coup
[Musique]